has the jury reached a verdict will you
please hand it to the bailiff and the
bailiff will bring it to me
thank you you may be seated
thank you we'll now have the clerk read
the verdict
was Gwyneth Paltrow at fault no
was Gwyneth Paltrow's fault a cause of
Terry sanderson's harm
oh
check that there's just no response
there
was Terry
yes
was Terry sanderson's fault it caused
Gwyneth Paltrow's
did um did Terry sanderson's fault cause
Gwyneth Paltrow's harm yes
comparative fault
what percent of the fault do you assign
to Terry Sanderson
100 percent
damages what amount fairly commensur
compensates Gwyneth Paltrow for economic
damages one dollar
signed March 30th 2023.
thank you